In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 20th, on which we commemorate St. Ilyia Chavceváce,
the just, in Georgia.
Born in 1837 into a devout family in the village of Cavreli in Eastern Georgia, St. Ilyia
was distinguished for his piety.
From his earliest childhood he desired to embrace the monastic life, but was unable to realize
his desire and gave himself to brilliant studies, first in Tbilisi, and then at the University
of St. Petersburg.
His natural gifts were thus able to flourish and he became an admirable poet, writer, publicist
and man of letters, appreciated in cultivated circles while remaining a humble and devout
Christian, zealous for the traditions of the Orthodox Church and his people.
By his writings and by his discourses and homilies St. Ilyia became the spiritual father
and teacher of the Georgian people.
Looking as the model for his own life, the lives and exploits of the saints, he often
expressed the image of the priest as a true, good shepherd, always ready to lay down
his life for his sheep.
He considered that piety linked to a disinterested love for the people and for one's country was
the essence of every human life and he knew how to inspire those who read his writings with
such Christian patriotism.
In all his activities he showed a profound sense of justice and encouraged the spiritual
education of his people.
Becoming a member of the government he worked for the abolition of the death penalty, for
the independence of Georgia and for the restoration of the autosephile of his church which earned
him the hatred of many.
He was savagely assassinated on the 30th of August in the year 1907 while traveling to the
village of Saguramo, thus obtaining the glory of the martyrs whom he had praised in his works.
The assassins were condemned to be hanged, but the saints Widow, Olga, interceded on their
behalf on the grounds that her husband would have done the same thing, seeing them as brethren
who have gone astray.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.